اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام
عند لقاء رئيس البرلمان الليبي عقيل صالح
مع رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري
في القاهره لمناقشه توحيد السلطه
التنفيذيه والمناصب السياديه والقاعده
الدستوريه للانتخابات ايضا مع ضيفي عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من القاهره سيد محمد
الاسمر البوزيدي مدير مركز الامه الليبيه
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه سيدنا محمد الاسمر
البوزيدي اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
على تربيه هذه الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا مرحبا حياكم الله مرحبا كل
الترحيب من طرابلس كل الترحيب ايضا دكتور
الياس الباروني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم ومرحبا وشكرا
جزيلا لك سيد الباروني على تلبيه هذه
الدعوه ان كنت تستمع اليه
دا بالاستاذ محمد ابو زيد من من ليبيا
مرحبا
[موسيقى]
وكل شكر جزيلا لكم على تلبيه هذه الدعوه
هو ليس الاول من نوع ما تعليقكم على هذا
اللقاء لقاء خالد المشري بعقيل صالح في
القاهره وعن الملفات الموضوع على جدول
الاعمال هذا اللقاء بهدف التواصل الى
تفاهمات تخرج ليبيا من حاله الجمود كما
ذكرت مصادر مقربه همم من هما اثر عليك
السؤال الاول من السيد محمد الاسمر
البوزيدي مدير مركز الامه الليبي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه مرحبا من جديد
يبدو ان الاشكال في الصوت كان مع سيد
البوزيدي تستمع اليه سيد محمد الاسمر
البوزيدي
لا يستمع اليه في انتظار معالجه هذا الخلل
التقني اطرح عليك السؤال انت دكتور الياس
الباروني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه تعليقك على هذا اللقاء المصري
صالح من جديد في القاهره
ما تعليقك على هذا اللقاء خاصه انا رئيس
مجلس النواب يقول انه سيتوافق مع مجلس
الدوله في الايام المقبله بشان الملف
المناصب السياديه التي تتبع وفق تعبيره
مجلس النوابته هي من اختصاصاته مرحبا من
جديد نعم نعم حكيم ليبيا تمر بظروف صعبه
ودقيقه للغايه في هذه الفتره همم كما
تعلمون ان ليبيا والشعب ليبيا انتظر من
البرلماني والاعلى همم المدير قدم نحو
تنفيذ الاستحقاق الانتخابي في ضمن قاعده
الدستوريه او تحويل مشروع الدستور الذي
سوت عليه من قبل لجنه الدستور 29 يوليو
للاستفتاء عليه الا عنا البرلماني وكذلك
الاع في هذه العمليه وبدا فعلا همم في
تشكيل حكومه نفاق الوطني بعد ذلك حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه اليوم يريدون عيدا
الانتقال بنا الى المرحله الانتقاليه
جديده في حكومه جديده وبالتالي ينقلون
الاشكاليه في ليبيا هي ليست مشكله سياسيه
بل هي مشكله دستوريه بالاحرى ولكن للاسف
يعمل البرلماني والاعلى للمدير قدم نحوه
تمديد اعمار همم شغلهم ما سب وكان على
مستوى الاعلى وكذلك البرلمان اليوم كان
بالامس ذهبوا الى الرباط ثم الان الى
القاهره همم من الشعب الاتفاق حول القاعده
الدستوريه ولكن
قفزاء بعيدا الى تشكيل سلطه او معنى همم
بتعلق بالراعي حول السلطه التنفيذيه ما
يعرف بتشكيل الحكومه جديده طيب نفس ما
قاله ال- همم
سيد دبيبه حتى عودي اليك سيد محمد اسمر
البوزيدي مدير مركز الامه الليبي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه واعتر اعتذر منكم المشاهدين
على الخل لترى على الصوت في بدايه مداخلته
همم يقول ضيفي من طرابلسيات لكون ويريدون
مرحله انتقاليه جديده اود ان اسالك عن
تعليقك بشان هذا اللقاء الذي ليس الاول من
نوع ما بين المشري وصالح في القاهره
والمواضيع المختلفه التي هي على جدول
الاعمال
اهلا وسهلا مرحبا حياكم الله الرؤيا
والمصلحه الوطنيه تقتضي بان ننظر لكافه
المبادرات وكذلك السلوك السياسي بمقياس
ومعيار واحد ان القول والذي يذهب اليه
السيد الدبيبه وفي تصريحات اليوم في
اجتماع مع تجمع لمواساه المجتمع المدني
حول الوصول الانتخابات بانها هؤلاء يريدون
اطاله فقط فتره وجودهم وهذه اجسام مترهله
ويجب السماح للتمديد وهؤلاء يتمسكون
بالسلطه حسنا اذا ما كان هذا الطرف هذا
المعيار فان المصلحه الوطنيه تقتضي ان
يكون هذا المعيار واحد السيد دبي لا يجوز
له باي شكل من الاشكال البقاء في السلطه
الى حد الان هو لم يتم اختياره شعبيه وذهب
للقول بانه همم اللي بيقولوا متمسكون به
وانه اتى باراده ورغبه شعبيه انه ملتقى
الحوار السياسي نعرفه جيدا الذي عقد بدايه
نوفمبر في تونس ثم في ملتقى
اوه نتجاب باليه معينه بعيده عن اختيارات
الشعب الليبي انها هذه المراحل الانتقاليه
بالاختيار الشعبي ولكن على كل حال الان
اللقاءات التي تعقد الان بين هل هي صحيحه
ااه هي خطوه يجب ان تكون يجب ان تكون
وبالتالي نحن نعلم مسبقا منذ الان منذ
الان ان لا نتائج مرجوع حتميه من هذه
الخطوه ولكنه يجب ان تقول لماذا لان
الاجراء الصحيح في ليبيا الان هو التزام
بالسياقات لمجلس النواب والشعر يعني
الدوله والحكومه والمجلس الرئاسي لانه
عندما تم انتاج الوضع الحالي اسس بهذه
الاجسام كل جسم من هذه الاجسام له
اختصاصات وعليه مهام يجب القيام بهذا
اللقاء كان يجب ان يقول في اللقاءات بين
الجانبين التي كانت في ابريل ثم ما ثمنه
في القاهره فين هذا العام لم يتسنى ذلك
كان لقاء المغرب الثاني والعشرين
والحادي 21 23 من اكتوبر وهذا استكمال
لهذا السياق ولكن في عجاله هنا الدوري
المفقود اين عندما يشكك الذبيبه في نيتها
هؤلاء وهؤلاء لا يريدون وجود دبي
الرجوع لما تم انتاجه من خلال البعثه
الامميه والامم المتحده وقرارات مجلس
الامن التي لم يتم تطبيقها الى حد الان
وان بتيري الذي استلم مهامه مطلعي سبتمبر
وذهب طرابلس ينصف اكتوبر لم ينطق ولو حتى
بوجهه نظر فقيه حول ما يحدث في ليبيا
بخصوصي السلطه وتداولها او انتاج حكومه
جديده وليست هناك ايه مواقف حتى لانه
يتواجد الان حتى في القاهره وذكر فقط بما
قاله دبي بهذا اليوم انه اتهم الاجسام
تشريعيه والاستشاريه بتعمد بتعطيل من منهج
الانتخابات تجاه الاراده الليبيين ويقول
لهذه الاجسام بشكل واضح نحن جميعا اكثر
حرصا منكم على انهاء المراحل الانتقاليه
فلا طريقا للانتخابات
والدستور اعود اليك ضيفه من طرابلس همم
السيد الياس الباروني استاذ علوم سياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه حاله وصوله الى القاهره
حمل كثيرا على حكومه قال انها فشلت فشلا
جاريا في اداء مها المتمثله في المصالحه
الوطنيه
الانتخابات وتوحيد المؤسسات وتوفير
المتطلبات المواطنين هل هو محاق في تقييم
هذا وهل نحن ماضونا فعلا اليوم نحو حكومه
ثالثه جديده ربما كما يروج بعض وتعقب ايضا
على مذهب اليه ضيفه السيد البوزيكي
نعم حكيم للاسف هذا الخطاب غير دقيق حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه منذ نشاتها تلكها البرلمان
في الاعتماد او منح الثقه الا انك منحه
الثقه بصعوبه بعد ذلك ذهب بعيدا الى عدم
اعتماد الميزان العامه هل تعلمون الان
حوالي سنه ونصف تقريبا الان همم الحكومه
تشتغل بدون ميزانيه عامه رغم ذلك رغم همم
البرلمان الا انك كانت هناك انجازات على
الارض سواء كانت على الصعيد البنيه
التحتيه كذلك ايضا الافراجات الماليه
تعلمون جيدا حكيم وايضا السيد محمد ابو
زيدي هناك 360 موظف لا يتقدون الرواتب منذ
حكومه الرفاق الوطني قامت هذه الحكومه
بالافراجات او ايضا عن اشكاليه في عمليه
النفاقات
الماليه وكذلك يتعلق باحتياجات الناس هذا
من ناحيه اما تتعلق بالمصالح الوطنيه
قاسم بتمثل في السيد محمد المنوفيه
قام هناك العديد من الخطوات وانا اا شرفت
بان اكون عضو في لجنه همم الخبراء للتخطيط
الوطني في ليبيا وتم عيدا تشكيله هذه
اللجنه واستغنى عليها لمده عام وراعين عين
الوضع رؤيه لمشروع المصالحه الوطنيه
والجنوبيه الحديث عن الفشل مردود عليه هذا
ما تقصده
نعم نعم نعم
انجازات في الحقيقه رغم التحديات الا ان
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه كان لها بصمه على
الشارع وعلى مستوى الراي العام اللي
بالكامل شرق الجنوب الغربه همم
هذه المرحله هذه المشاورات الان في
القاهره ستقود الى مرحله الانتقاليه جديده
وربما الى حكومه الثالثه هذا سؤال
نعم نعم حكيم للاسف هنا يريد صالح والمشري
يريد رئيس حكومه كذلك ايضا عاجله
صالحاسي ونحن لا نريد ذلك نريد فعل الشعب
الليبي يريد انتخابات على مستوى البرلماني
حق البرلمان يقوم بالتحويل على الدستور
وان هذه المراحل الانتقاليه الفائزه طيب
وكل الاطراف تتقاذف المسؤوليه بالالتهامات
في هذا شان انتهت مدتها حتى تعود اليك سيد
البوزيدي همم يقول عقيل صالح متحدثا عن
الحكومه اتت بمهام محدده ولكنها فاشلت هل
فشلت فعلا من وجهه نظرك وهل يكون مش لصالح
هذا حاسما بالنسبه لمسيره بيبه وحكومته
بعض الاطراف تتحدث اليوم عن سيناريو اول
اما اول لدمج الحكومتين الحاليتين مع
اقناعه احاديث رئيسيهم بالانسحاب او ربما
سيناريو الثاني بتشكيل حكومه مصغره تصريف
الاعمال تصل بليبيا الى الانتخابات في
اسرع وقت ممكن وانت في القاهره ما
المعلومات المتوفره لديك
همم اولا فلنبدا بما هو مامول في
الاحتمالات المطروحه ثم نذهب الى اداء همم
الحكومه السنوات الثلاثه المطروحه لا يمكن
لاي منها ان تكون متحققه على وجه الارض
يمكن للبرلمان مع مجلس الدوله ان يكلف
حكومه ثالثه سواء حكومه مصغره لتصريف
الاعمال وحتى اذا كان الحكومه بتنازل احد
الطرفين وهو بعيد جدا ستكون في عضويتها
ادخال لطرف اخر غير موجود في الوزارات
وخاصه من الحساسه وهنا السيد دبي الحقيقه
هو قد تصدر منذ شهر ابريل المشهد بان قال
ان لا تسليما الا للحكومه المنتخب
وبالتالي تجاوز كل هذه المجهودات وكل هذه
المقترحات والا قبول يعني نحن عندنا نقول
تم تكليف حكومه جديده فل يكون ذلك لكن هل
يسلم البيب مقالي سلطه الطراب لصوفيا
لهذه الحكومه المنتجه على الاطلاق وسبب في
ذلك لغياب الجهه الثالثه الضابطه الراعيه
لما يتم الاتفاق عليه في المشهد الليبي
وهو البعثه الاميه التي لا تمارس اي
صلاحيات نشاهد انه بحلول الرابع والعشرين
من ديسمبر حصلت الانتخابات ام لم تحصل من
العام الماضي فان للبرلمان وفق لخال طريقه
لمكلفه حكومه الاخرى او يمدد دبيبه حتى
الثانيه والعشرين من
كحكومه التي تصريف اعمال وصرحت بذلك
ستيفاني في السابعه عشر من ديسمبر في
اجتماعاتها في بنغازي بحتميه هذا النص
وبقته وعندما لم يتم تطبيق ذلك لم يتم شجب
تمسك الدبيبه الى حد الان هذا من الناحيه
من الناحيه الاخرى همم المهام والاداء هو
مقياس عمل الحكومه عندما يتحدث مثلا ضيف
الكريم هناك الكثيره تحدث عن ذلك وخاصه من
طرف دبيبه بان كان هناك اداءا طيب شكرا
بارك الله فيكم الاداء في الحكومات ليس
بالعمل التطوعي وليس بالصدقات هذه مهام
ممكن للحكومه والاداء يكون في اطار الام
الممكله وخاصه الصلاحيه الزمنيه اذ انه تم
تحديث صلاحيه بمهمات للاعداد للانتخابات
ولم يتم الالتزام بها واذا ما نظرنا ايضا
لخطاب الدبيبه عن حالتي والجاهزيه لتامر
الانتخابات نور نودوا فقط الانتباه عن
المقاييس والمعايير في ذلك في التاسع
والعشرين من نوفمبر من العام الماضي
والعماليه الانتخابيه قائمه همم صرح وزير
الداخليه في حكومه دبي السيد خالد مازن
بان الحكومه على تم الاستعداد للتامين في
كافه انحاء ليبيا طيب صبيحه الثلاثين من
نوفمبر في اليوم الذي يليه صدره الطعون ضد
السيد الذبيبه صرح عشيه ذلك اليوم خالد
مازن بعد 24 ساعه الا امكانيه عند الحكومه
لتامين هذه الانتخابات عقليه بهذا الشكل
لا يمكن تامينها لمسيره الانتخابات عموما
هذه الحوصله ما بين اداء جيد وحسن ومهام
لم يتم الالتزام بها يجب الالتزام
بالضوابط التي كل اقرها على نفسه وانضى
عليها ووقعها واقسم ماء بذلك لكي تكون
العمليه السياسيه في سياقها نعم تكون
عمليه سياسيه في سياقها والاطراف جميعها
اا الدوليه منها تدعو الى التسعه في هذه
العمليه السياسيه لست ادري كيف يمكننا ان
اول تصريحات المبعوث الاممي السيد باتيلي
وهو في القاهره بعد ما التقى وزير
الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري امامي
تغريداته يقول التقيت مع معالي السيد سمح
شكري همم تبدلنا الاراء حول الوضع في
ليبيا دعانا الاطراف الفاعله الى تسريع
العمليه السياسيه لانهاء الازمه فتح
السبيل امام الانتخابات والسلام
والاستقرار وضروره التنسيق المجتمع الدولي
للجهود دعم الفرقاء كيف يمكن تاويل هذه
تصريحات ولكن سؤالي الى اي مدى تتم هذه
التحركات في القاهره حيث يوجد المبعوث
الاممي الى اي مدى تتم بموافقه القوى
الاقليميه الرئيسيه اللاعبه في المشهد
الليبي وعلى راسها مصر وتركيا والامم
المتحده باضافه الى دول الغربيه
الاخرى خاصه وخاصه وخاصه بعد مصافحه
السيسي واردوغان قبل اسبوع ااا سيد الياس
الباروني هل عمليه تتم مباركه جماعيه همم
دوليه
نعم حكيم لو لاحظتهم القرار الاخيره لصدر
من مجلس الامن 26 56 في النقطه او البند
الرابع في متعلق بمفتاح بين قوسين تشكيل
حكومه تبسه يدل على كم التراب اللي بيه
وهذا وهذا المصطلح همم تم تاويله وتفسيره
من عده وجوه حكومه الوحده الوطنيه اعتبرته
همم تشديد لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
واعتبرها همم تايدا له وكذلك البرنامج
يذهب بعيدا الى تشكيل الحكومه ثالثه على
حكومه بشارع حكومه الوطنيه هذا في نفس
الوقت ايضا لا نجد ايضا موقف دولي واقليمي
واضح في ال- في الرعب في الرؤيا في حل
الازمه الليبيه نجد ان هناك تحركات في
الجزائر كذلك في الرباط المغرب واخيرا في
القاهره
وتونس الان بالامكان ان تكون فاعله في
المشهد الليبي حتى تقوم
برسم او مساعده في رسم رؤيه واضحه وتوافق
عليها شرع ليبيا من الداخل ودايدا القوه
الاقليميه والدوليه يتم نحن الان امام
اشكاليه كبيره في متعلق بالتدخل الاقليمي
والدوري في الحاله الازمه الليبيه اين
هناك اراده دوليه واقليميه تفرض نفسه على
ارض الواقع على غرار ايضا همم المشري
وصالح يريدان باي طريقه كان كانت تشكيل
الحكومه جديده ويكون على راس هذين الجسمين
اذا كان على مستوى على المجلس السياسي او
على المستوى الحكومه احيانا الصمت يبعث في
اشارات متناقضه سيد محمد الاسمر البوزيدي
همم وربما هو الخشيه من التدخل في شان
الداخلي الليبي بشكل مباشر ولكن اودعنا
سالك او انت في القاهره وعود الى هذه
النقطه تحديدا لانها مهمه تقارب مصر
وتركيا بعد خلاف وتوتر هل يفتح الباب
الاهل نحو التوافقات جديده في ليبيا هل
يسهل هل الحلقات الازمه هل القوه الكبرى
من بينها فرنسا والولايات المتحده الى
جانب القوى الاقليميه وخاصه مصر اتدعم
تحركات المشري وصالح في القاهره هل تم ضوء
اخضر سيد البوزيدي
هو اا اخي الكريم تصنيف الصمت اللي ينطبق
لي على الشعب الليبيا الكل يتكلمون في
الشعب الليبي في شان الشعب الليبي الا
الشعب الليبي المحروم حتى من همم مرتبات
وقوته يومه وامنه واستغاري حتى الدول التي
تعاني من مشاكل الداخليه
ان تنفذ دورا في ليبيا طبعا هذا من الاتي
الوضع العام لكن على كل حال الان التوجهات
والمعطيات الدوليه مما لا شك فيه ليبيا
تتاثر بهذه التقاطعات وهذه التجاذبات
التوافق المصري التركي ليست جديد قد سبقوا
خطوات في 2020 وكانت اللجنه همم
المشتركه وسميت بالجنه استشرافيه لجسم
النبض ما بين الطرفين وكانت ليبيا حاضره
انا ذاك مصر لديها رؤيه معينه في همم
مشاريع تركيا في ليبيا ولكن الان في الوضع
العام ليه بيجوز المهم من التوافق المصري
التركي لان الان اساس الخلاف بشكل كبير
ليس الموضوع الامني الموضوع الامني فيما
يخص مصر وحتى من ناحيه قوميه وعربيه تم
تحديده في بيان 2020 وخط الجفره صرت هو
الذي ضمنته دول اخرى وتم تحديد هذا العمق
ولكن تبقى قصه شرق المتوسط والمنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه التي تم توقيعها مع
حكومه الوفاق في ال26 نوفمبر 2019
وتثبيتها بمذكره التفاهم في الثالث من
اكتوبر الماضي هي المحور وبالتالي لا
تغيرات وتجاوبات كثيره وننظر هنا بالمقياس
والمعيار حتى تركيا وروسيا وهم على شد
خلاف بينهما مصالح ومصالح كبيره جدا وتلقي
بظلالها في ليبيا وبالتالي اعاده توزيع
الادوار والانماط والتقاطعات والتجاذبات
وفقا للمصالح وشاهدنا الذرواتها عند توقيع
مشروع حسين في يناير 2020 بين روسيا
وتركيا لمرور الغاز
الروسي الى اوروبا عبر تركيا وكانت هناك
الصراعات ومواجهات الشرق فيها الطرفين
مباشره على وجه الارض ولكن الم العامل
الان السائد على هذه اللقاءات في القاهره
هو ما صرح به سامح شكر في بدايه لقاءه مع
بتيلي ان لا مجهودات يمكن تكون مثمره الا
اذا ما قامت الامم المتحده بالتزام
بمهامها ومئالت به على نفسها في قارات
التي اصدرتها والمواضي والاليات التي
تبنتها في ليبيا اين يتم الاتفاق على منهج
معين ولا يتم متابعتهم الامم المتحده
هل تم تتوافق باختصار شديد هل تم مبارك هل
تم اخضر هل تم دعم لهذه المحادثات في همم
في القاهره بين المشري وعقيله صالح من اجل
كما قال همم البعض من المقربين منها همم
الطرفين اخراج البلاد من حاله الجمود
باختصار لو سمحت
النتائج لكي نوجز اختصارا في هذا الدعم
تصريح المستشار الاعلامي للسيد رئيس مجلس
النواب قال انه لحد الان لا يوجد توافق
على فقره اختيار الرئيس بن ناحيه جنسيه
المزدوجه وترشح العسكريين القائد
الدستوريه لازالت مجمده وتشكيل حكومه
ثالثه لحد الان لملامح ولا رؤيه له ولا
اتفاق دوري اصلا على المقترحات الثلاثه
وبالتالي تمديد عمر الازمه في ليبيا وان
2023 مطابخ ل 2020 وقال لما الامح
الانتخابات لحد الان لا يوجد موعد حتى
جدول زمني مرتقب لهذه الانتخابات طيب لدي
دقيقتان فقط واختم بهذا السؤال لكما
السيده دبيبه سارعه بالرد من مؤتمر
المجتمع المدني للانتخابات ونحو
الانتخابات قائلا انه مستعد للتواصل مع
الجميع دون استثناء وتجاوز كل الخلافات
بعد يعتبرها ربما دعى للحوار والاستجابه
لاي مبادره لتعزيز الثقه بين مكونات الشعب
الفاعله وليست السلبيه واعتبر ان الحوار
الوطني بديل المواصفها بالصفقات المشبوهه
لبعض اعتبرها رساله مضمونه الوصول الرمليه
الى لقاء المشري صالح في القاهره ما
تعليقكم على هذه التصريحات وهل يمكن وعلى
دعوه الحوار هذا في اقل من دقيقه لو سمحت
سيد الباروني واختم مع سيد بوزيدي دائما
بهذا الشان
نعم حكيم فهذا الصدر من لجنه 120 اشرنا
بان الحلال
على تحفيده لتحقيق الانتخابي وفقه همم
اعلانا الدستوري الذي تم على غياره او على
اسره انتخابات المؤتمر العام وايضا خروج
جميع الاجسام سواء كانت الاعلى والبرلمان
والحكومه عدم متابعته وعدم سيطرته على
مجالات الانتخابيه وفي نفس الوقت ايضا خلك
منتدى للحوار يشمل مشروع مدني الاحزاب
كذلك الاعين والحكماء الاعتماد للاعلان
الدستوري لسنه 2012 وكذلك عيدا القانون
الذي تم انتخابات العام السابق وبالتالي
يخرج من هذه الازمه ونساعد الحكومه وكذلك
الاعلى في تنفيذ هذا الاستحقاق بعيدا عن
هذه الاجسام الذي كتب عليه الذي سيكون في
تونس الاربعاء يقول انا مستعد للتواصل مع
الجميع دون استثناء والح الوطني همم بديل
عن الصفقات المشبوهه اختم معك همم سيد
محمد الاسمر بوزيد في اقل من دقيقه لو
سمحت ايضا
ليس لدينا في شان الليبي طرف التوقيت
والفترات الزمنيه المسموح بها لتداول
حوارات جديده ومبادرات لانه قبل كل ذلك
حتى مبادره الاخوه 120 شخصيه وقبلها في
الثالث من اغسطس مبادره العديد من
التيارات وتجميع اكثر 250,000 توقيعه تم
عرضها على البرلمان ومجلس الدوله التوقيت
الان كل التزما بما نصت عليه الاتفاقات
السياسيه الضابطه والحاكمه للمشروع
السياسي في ليبيا لان اي مبادرات ما لم
يتم الالتزام بذلك غير ناجحه مع من يتحاور
وهو ينظر الى الاخرين مختلفين
يصنفونه بانه مخالف والمتضرر الشعب الليبي
ونكرر 2023 امل اذا ما ضل الوضع كما هو
علينا يعني نشكركم جزيل الشكر على هذه
الحلقه من القاهره سيد محمد اسمر بوزيدي
مدير مركز الامه للدراسات استراتيجيه شكرا
جزيلا لك وكل الشكر جزيلا لك ايضا من
طرابلس دكتور الياس الباروني استاذ علوم
السياسيه والع الدوليه كنت ما معنا في
فقره وجها لوجه